the Joe Rogan experience I've been
following your work for a long time man
I mean I was first introduced to you and
your methods by Steve Maxwell who was a
you know a huge proponent of the
kettlebell then I started getting into
your very yeah very good and I started
getting into your videos and I've read
your books and so thank you it's an
honor my pleasure how long have you been
teaching and practicing with kettlebells
since you're a little something like
that medium that's it's Alex baseball
you know he's pretty common in Russia in
this area tuna yeah it is
why didn't he catch on here until you
came over here you know what I don't
think people really tried I don't think
people really understood that would
catch on and I did not think it would
happen either
so I'm sitting with my friend Marty
Gallagher having steaks years back marty
is a former coach for bar lifting team
USA and coach of some top lifters
anywhere just trading old war stories
started talking about stuff and I'd tell
him about kettlebells he says well
you've got to teach Americans how to do
that and I said Marty you don't
understand this stuff is too hard
nobody's gonna want to do this and he
said you don't understand people want to
do this and I wrote an article for based
on Marty's suggestion for Milo so Milo
was a publication niche publication for
strange guys who lift rocks and bend
things and break things and so on and so
forth and so that was the start of it
and then after that I told my publisher
about it and he said well come on let's
just make kettlebells and teach people I
had told them the same thing
you don't understand that people will
not want to do this this is too hard and
but he convinced me and they convinced
me and the rest is history
why did you think that it was popular in
the Soviet Union but wouldn't be popular
in America you know this is something
that you just see it's very common thing
Joe so you just see this you don't think
much about this who knows yeah but it
was popular over there yeah and since at
least since at least seven
hundreds or possibly before that but
this country is so performance oriented
and so sports oriented and so
competitive why wouldn't you think that
that would be sort of a natural training
modality that way they would immediately
adopt it you got me there
[Applause]